I would maybe I would maybe do.
Hold on a second.
Don't,
don't say a word.
Don't say a word.
Don't say a word until this bitch gets cracking.
Bert Kreischer.
I want you to keep it together.
I want you to hold on.
I'm holding,
wants you to realize this is a gun damn commercial free podcast.
Exceptional addition is an except the podcast was so good.
It cannot be stopped or the greater good of Shiva or Odin or Thor or Cassiopeia.
Did anybody ever wash up?
Cassiopeia is at the watch.
Some chick with some dude probably wanted to fuck and he got all exaggerated
when she was named bear of fucking constellation or some shit,
right?
Cassiopeia I bet her website's available.
That's good.
Is your pussy you have to be before they named it constellation after it.
Not even like a tree.
Why on a rock,
not a mountain.
No.
A series of nuclear explosions and the middle of the universe.
Why haven't they rebooted Thor and like he got a haircut yet because [inaudible]
he's dope.
Don't be,
hey,
listen,
Brian,
you have a full head of hair.
You shouldn't be hating because I have almost zero hair and I'm not hating.
Okay?
It's a matter of time before I shaved my head.
It's your issues.
He should do it.
I just want to to the hair green things.
Oh yeah,
dude.
Shaving your head is a beautiful feeling.
Is it?
Do it.
Just do it.
Trust me.
Just do it once.
You obviously don't give a fuck about your body.
Let's be realistic.
You've,
he's been working out a lot.
You're not gay.
You're you.
Let's be honest.
You know,
I love you,
but let's be honest.
If you were entering into a bodybuilding contest,
I would say this guy does not want to win.
He is not trying to win sexiest.
Man.
I don't even look good in European speedo.
Oh,
not that there's anything wrong with that,
but let's be honest about our paths.
It's life,
ladies and gentlemen.
So death,
a death squad,
Scotland and desk got Ohio are losing their fucking minds because they're told
you to stop communicating with those people.
You don't know them.
You have not vetted them,
sir.
Brian does know,
goddammit.
None of them mother fuckers have a proper filter in place.
We need to fucking set ups a scientific checks and balances.
Much like the CIA uses.
Can't just decide.
You're going to let some mother fucker send you some whiskey.
Oh,
I can't put coconut.
We have a refrigerator here at a higher primates studios.
We're so not fucking around,
ladies and gentlemen.
Okay.
We were taking this to the next level.
Bert Kreischer.
Do you see what we're doing here?
My own Buddha.
His fucking care package from on it.
Yeah.
You got a care package from on it.
Then we got the boot are responsible for my tattoo.
What was that?
The Buddha taught like,
hi guys are here.
You're done.
But Tattoos.
Are you going to,
are you going to,
I'm going to fill in my right arm.
Can we see your right?
That is the same.
Hmm.
The guy who did my arm,
first of all,
he's a beautiful artist and he's a cool mother fucker name is Aaron Dellavedova
and he uh,
works at Guru Tattoo in San Diego.
I get,
I would get tattoo just to hang out with that dude.
It's so cool.
I wonder if that,
I want to heal.
He's a real artist.
He usually eats really cool paintings.
I love his,
like his point of view.
Like it's so uniquely his own that you remember that guy that was uh,
uh,
Jesse James Rather,
who's married to Sandra Bullock.
Remember he had that affair with some girl at Swat to Roscoe touch with him
before I saw no,
no,
no.
She didn't have that.
No,
no,
no.
She was not a swipe power.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
she did.
How she did you?
She did not.
No,
no,
no.
She had swastikas tattooed.
So stop it.
Stop.
No,
swear to God.
she's really good at telling you.
I'll be showing you.
I'm telling you you're wrong.
What's her name is Michelle dynamite or something like that.
But anyway,
my point is that she had this sleeve and I looked at the sleeve and I said,
that's an Aaron Dellavedova Tattoo.
I could tell that his style is so distinctive and I'm uh,
I'm,
I'm such a huge fan of individual points of expression.
Why?
Or like,
um,
like there's certain like pool cues where you could look at the pool cue and you
know,
that is a sugar tree.
That's a cue that Eric,
Chris May,
that is a cognizant d that's acute,
that Joe Gold Mate,
but they have like this individual point of expression.
Michelle,
my gate.
Yeah.
She did a Nazi.
That's what it was.
She want to have it attached.
Yeah.
She doesn't have tattoos like some crazy photo shoot that she had to do.
Although it does say WP on her leg.
Yeah.
As in white power.
No.
Or how would it means or,
whoa.
Is that really what it means?
WP?
I'll think.
What else.
Oh,
uh,
with the coupe,
what was my point about her?
Uh,
you were talking about,
uh,
you're a tattoo artist.
Had her arm or something.
I saw her arm and one for arms.
I think it's a right sleeve.
Yeah.
His style is so distinct.
Did you start check out?
Well,
I looked on in California and I was looking at all these different,
you know,
it's like you,
if you,
there's a lot of really good artists in California,
especially,
you mean Kat von D who we've had on the podcast.
Oh,
was a great podcast.
Yeah,
she was really cool.
There's this,
uh,
there's just,
there's so many,
like I don't even want to name names.
Yes,
there's a million talented artists,
but when I saw Aaron's work on mine,
especially sleeves and big back pieces,
like his style is really about big bold like pieces.
And when I started talking to him like immediately we hit it off,
I was like,
this girl is cool as fuck.
He's so cool.
Like right away.
Like I was like,
like you know what,
you talk to someone,
you really like happy to have a conversation with them.
And we like on a the perfect level.
Like you really like it,
you know,
both of us were talking about all kinds of different crazy shad and he's,
or he's an honorable person and he's an artist is like right away.
I was like,
I love this guy.
Know right away.
It's a perfect guy to do it.
What did you guys,
uh,
if,
if you remember,
I'm curious to see if you remember.
What did you guys talk about while he was tattooing you?
Everything and anything,
man.
Do you remember any of the conversation?
Like is it,
we have it on it,
like a meaningful,
at the beginning.
First Sleeve?
Yeah.
At the beginning of the first leak.
A lot.
It was on video,
but then the second sleeve is like,
like about three years old.
I still have to go back.
I still,
there's a few spots on it.
It's amazing.
Most of it is a memo to Musashi peace.
Who is the guy who is the,
Oh,
and there's the graphics joker.
I thought you got rid of the graphics Cherokee.
Yeah.
I thought you did too.
I have to suck.
It's not quite done yet.
I got it.
I think they should pump that out.
No,
it's like,
it's not really,
even before I knew what a graphics joke or what you drew it,
right.
Stupid idea.
Yeah.
I drew it.
But I caught that shit.
That's my Jiu Jitsu.
But,
uh,
this is Jamison experience.
That Tattoo.
I did draw a lot.
I drew that in 1990.
It looks like shit now.
I like it.
Oh,
the guy who better than water,
if the guy who tattooed
for me,
it did a fucking brilliant job,
but steam was Danny Williams and he died of a,
of cancer really?
Reselling and the bottom tattoo.
They're really crazy looking.
Samurai guy that is a meal Molto Musashi and he's fighting a tiger and that.
So what happened?
What happened to you?
Sick artwork,
man.
So that's all my man Aaron Dellavedova his work and he just,
he does brilliant work.
It's,
yeah,
the beach.
What was the,
what was the term for what
for you?
Like where were you,
you went from like one tattoo and not smoking weed to like,
well,
I don't,
maybe I've heard say no
was,
um,
I,
I always like,
like tattoos.
I always liked the artwork of it.
I'm a big fan of,
I'm a big fan of music.
I'm a big fan of writing.
I'm a big fan of meat movies and cars and,
and,
and paintings and anything that you do that expresses whatever you have inside
of yourself through some medium,
whether it's a medium of making a hot rod or it's the medium of even designing
clothes.
Like I'm like,
like I'm wearing some crazy tee shirt right now.
Some dude gave me,
it's a Bruce Lee who's a,
he's acting as a DJ.
I thought that was hilarious.
So,
but it's great.
It's funny,
someone's idea that's expressed through clothes,
you know,
you can express it through furniture.
I like
my friend away in this table tables,
bad ass.
And
you can express it through anything,
but it really,
it's all the same thing.
The eye,
the idea is that everything that a person can enjoy is someone else trying to
express some sort of positive through whatever medium it is.
Whether it's a fucking,
well,
there's les Miserables,
50 shades of grey.
It's all the same thing.
But what was the turning point?
Do you remember the thing?
No,
I know I was probably some psychedelic drug related to experience.
Most likely.
Yeah.
That was the the
but what got you there?
Um,
well if marijuana is a gateway drug,
I'm really unfortunately a good example.
I don't think
that it's a negative gateway.
I think we have to get over that idea.
And I think a big part of the struggle that we have in this country,
it's a lot of conservative people misunderstand the position of people that,
uh,
support marijuana or cannabis.
And it doesn't mean that they're mutually exclusive and it doesn't mean that
they have to be in combat with each other.
It just means that for whatever reason,
as a society,
we have associated cannabis smokers and users with lazy bitches.
And that's stupid.
And I think that if I have benefited as a,
an unnecessarily aggro,
you no child of the 80s if I have benefited from the magical gift of marijuana,
then I bet you can too.
It just needs to be used properly and it's going to make you examine yourself in
a way that may be uncomfortable but is most likely necessary.
You know,
and the ideas that we have connected to any sort of psychedelic experience,
marijuana or pay,
Yo the knee,
you name it,
mushrooms automatically people of a conservative nature.
We'll assume that the people involved in doing this thing or being lazy or
they're being,
they're being frivolous,
they're being frivolous because they've decided to like seek escape through
chemicals rather than deal with the reality.
But if they really knew,
they would know that that's not the case.
If they really had experienced,
they would know that.
No,
it's exact opposite.
This,
I hate to fucking bring up this God damn radio lab show again.
They were talking about religious experiences and people who did acid and,
and they,
and there was uh,
there was,
uh,
they were talking about they took these kids,
it's too in school.
Took him down to a church setting where a church sermon was giving,
going on.
They're all religious teachers.
Okay.
All religious teachers.
I like religious students.
They all take acid and they hear a sermon,
the church,
the beautiful bells.
And they said that nine out of 10 people in the test group,
so there's 2010 have,
uh,
a bullshit,
you know,
the placebo,
10 of the one,
nine,
nine of the 10 had a religious experience.
And they were saying that that nine out of 10 also went on to teach in the
ministry,
like nine of the 10 people that took acid.
And they were talking about the concept of whether or not you could do acid and
whether or not you could create original religious experience.
And if you could,
why wouldn't you have that all the time?
Well,
I wouldn't ever want to look for,
well,
what's what we were talking about earlier,
but like one day maybe we can get our shitty brains to accept a state of opiate
and Mgma at the same time all the time.
I want like a low grade cocaine.
What's going on?
I mean,
all respect to people who are on antidepressants.
And this is not an antidepressant rant.
And I think quite honestly,
that there's quite a few of those rants that,
or they're ignorant.
And even though,
you know,
we,
we had,
um,
a conversation with,
Kara Santa Maria who was on [inaudible],
I fucking loved her.
That girl was so fucking,
I've,
I've regurgitated some of her facts in conversation,
not realizing I'm doing it.
I fucking was.
So I was afraid to Google her and see what she looked like.
So I was like,
what is,
she's not hot because she was so hot on this podcast.
Just listen to her.
You were like,
oh,
she's beautiful.
More importantly,
she's very fascinating.
Very,
very fascinating.
And what was my point?
Uh,
I think psychedelics are about three of them in a row.
Psychedelics,
are you taking that off?
Yeah,
next week.
I'm taking her home.
He wanted to double date?
Nope.
Trying to can just hinted rubbing his tickets
point was that she was describing her own personal benefit from,
uh,
from using antidepressants and her own personal,
you know,
her,
her personal benefit from like regulating her state of consciousness,
but with the use of science.
And if you really stop and think about it,
like the,
some of the best feelings that I've ever had have been under the,
uh,
under the influence of chemicals.
You know,
whether it's right now or whether it's,
you know,
the first time I ever did anything which was an Mtma anything of significance
when,
when that feeling is so sensational.
Like what would life be if that feeling existed all the time?
We automatically have this thought in our head that that cannot be managed and
that needs to be discarded right away immediately for the state of consciousness
that exist right now can never be elevated.
This is what it is,
but I don't know even know that's true.
I Aye.
Aye.
I wonder sometimes because I go like,
okay,
I,
I feel like I spend my day chasing,
chasing a buzz where it's like,
like coffee in the morning and then there's just like dead period in the
afternoon.
I'm like,
well,
before the beer cart,
when you feel it's respectable to start drinking at five,
5:00 PM 5:00 PM
5:00 PM,
they can say,
leave me alone.
Oh God.
At work.
Who keeps the fucking lights on.
Some of the best moments of my life are when my wife had a job.
We were living in a,
in an apartment complex.
We had a nanny only because I was on the road and sometimes the nanny and I
would overlap and I'd be there when she would be there.
The best feelings my kids are,
they're sunsetting in Hollywood.
My wife fucking end up in the door and just go and do,
they won't open a bottle of wine.
Oh motherfucker.
I remember getting like chills like it's Christmas Eve and we crack open a
bottle of wine pouring for the nanny.
We just sit on the couch.
It's socks.
Fuck love.
I love those kind of moments.
You love leg ultimate moments where everybody agrees.
Yes,
it's time.
Everyone's on the same page.
I think that's one of the back open the bottle.
Everybody agrees.
It's great.
Like that's why you like sort of the ultimate party meister.
It's like you're the guy that would get everybody.
Ah,
fuck it.
Bert was do chef,
let's do shop,
but we do it a shot.
Give me a hug.
You fucks.
I love Ya.
And everybody would get together.
I think.
Yeah,
I love that feeling.
And when,
when like it's like just fucking,
someone just goes,
uh,
I go was going to be awkward if I order a beer and some would be like,
if you get one,
I'll get one.
I'm like,
we're fucking
right away.
Can love that feeling.
I think that's what the feeling people get when they connect when they smoked
marijuana is that someone likes it and then they're like,
Nah.
They're like,
oh,
okay.
Like it's such a great,
like there's definitely a thing that comes with being like in that sort of
fraternity of people that know,
you know,
then no,
you'd smoked pot.
Everybody's in.
It's like,
oh,
we're all cool.
And it was right.
As much as you sort of accepts that traditional notion of reality.
Like if you've never gotten high,
you and I have very little to talk about.
I mean,
we can talk about a few things for certain,
we can talk about facts and Statistics and history and numbers.
We can talk a lot about a lot of things,
but we can't talk about what the fuck is going on.
When you think about someone and then the phone rings and it's them,
you can't talk about that because you're going to give me some scaredy cat
answer.
You're going to go well,
it was just sort of a coincidence,
no relationship whatsoever.
There's never been a statistical correlation between you think the mount someone
and then them calling you and not meaning anything significant whatsoever.
It's just nonsense.
I need you to get a rip and put a tie on where some shiny shoes with slippery
souls and walked down the street like a gentleman.
I don't know.
But I know that when I,
a little light bulb goes off in my head and I think about Bert Kreischer and
then I looked down at my phone and it starts ringing immediately and it's Bert
Kreischer,
well call me crazy,
but I think something's up.
Okay.
I think there's something fucking going on when I think about you and then all
of a sudden you call me immediately.
It happens every day nonstop,
a lot.
And you know when it happens,
you ready for this Brian Red Ban.
It happens
live in your life correctly.
When you live in your life correctly,
the universe gives you a lot of fucking secret messages.
That's what it is.
I like yesterday,
this is something crazy.
As an example,
yesterday I was talking to my friend who's a ginger and I'm like,
is there such things as Jewish ginger's I've never even heard is like I've never
seen a Jewish ginger before.
She was like,
of course there is and then like two hours later it's somebody else just is
like,
oh,
this guy,
he's a gr ginger.
He's a Jewish gender.
Have you ever seen one of them?
I'm like,
all right,
I've never talked about ginger Jewish ginger's my whole entire life now twice in
one day
there's a possibility that you attracted down.
There's a possibility that much like you ever sent an email on Google,
you know it could be about anything.
You can just like send an email and say,
hey man,
I'm looking to get a life size copy of the robot from lost in space
base and then you look in the corner of your Gmail when you get on.
I ended up,
y'all lost in space shit.
That's reading.
Right,
right,
right.
Exactly.
So you think somebody is reading my presently,
this is my point.
If reality is a simulation wouldn't have followed the same principles that your
g-mail or your Yahoo has,
where you'll see the corners where shit you've sent emails about,
we'll be reoccurring themes in your life and do that in life all the time.
I've put it out there,
but isn't it fascinating it out there is it mirrors.
It mirrors what we know is a program.
Oh,
that's fucked up.
It's true.
You're right.
Yeah.
It's just the fucking natural course of history of how life's going to go down.
It already happens in life.
God does it well.
The universe does.
It trickles onto you.
You sound like you're right for a cult.
I could fucking gate you just shut up and write something.
Give me some Blue Nike Suck my Dick and a house full of feathers
I could be called.
I've been watching this
documentary on the vice guys and made a documentary about this fucking dude
who's a,
he's the new Jesus.
He's a Siberian Jesus.
Have you seen that Brian?
Listen,
ladies and gentlemen,
pull it up.
No,
we shouldn't pull it up because it's a really long piece.
You guys are crazy.
I've only watched the first two 10 minute pieces,
but it's fascinating.
There's a guy in Siberia that's created a village and he's like the second
coming of Jesus.
He's like the new Jesus,
and he has thousands of people that they're living up there.
Thousands.
They're all living up there.
But meanwhile,
they're living in an unbelievably,
unbelievably beautiful place.
I mean,
it is stunning.
If maybe maybe seeding if find some photos,
but it's,
it's staggeringly beautiful.
And this guy,
he's not p appreciate anything bad except being a Vegan.
That's silly.
But
I can't think of it.
I got to have for me Vegan fucking,
even when I was doing that clean program,
Jesus,
I'd have a chicken with fucking lettuce wraps.
Oh,
I love spicy shit.
Yeah.
I wish that animals weren't so fucking delicious.
It's the fucking amazing and I wish that they didn't fucking keep making
animals.
Maybe they would just all live forever and everyone will be a mortal.
We have enough numbers now and just keep it going.
I had duck heartland who?
The photo of the dude.
Who's the,
the Russian Jesus.
Meanwhile he's got an awesome,
I don't think I ever saw Jesus smile.
He does.
What?
Green Day's plans.
Sad cause he's hurt the [inaudible] Jesus.
His pictures were like hip hop cover albums.
I just was up
the Australian,
Jesus is a guy in Queensland and he says he's
Jesus.
It was just in Queensland.
What's that guy love level you do.
Are you doing to stand up?
No,
he did a triplet and Australia in Queensland.
Australia.
A country I've ever been to.
I'm telling you what to say this and I don't,
I'm not shitting on America and I'm not shitting on Kanuka Candida.
Can you guys are second.
But Australia blows everyone.
Yeah,
I love,
I love the people there.
I love their attitude.
It's like we,
we are so uptightness country,
we're,
we're really so unbelievably uptight,
especially when it comes to like going out and having fun and relaxed.
I'd moved to Australia in a fucking heartbeat in a heartbeat.
It's like there's this thing about America that America was sort of founded and
created by a bunch of people that have come here from somewhere that sucked and
they had enough and they just made it over to some new spot.
But I think that the,
the,
the type of person that it takes to be able to get in a boat and travel across
the ocean and land line is finding the land.
I think it takes several,
the generations before everybody fucking relaxes.
That's the bad ass.
Motherfuckers that could get a boat had fucking do that because you just shook
the,
the loose leaf.
Scott shaking off the tree.
There were,
there was so gangster,
they gotten a goddamn boat and traveled across.
You ever do that ends with no radio,
right?
Do you ever think about that though?
When you travel with your kids somewhere and then you go,
how would we travel across America?
Like how would,
how would your family size up in a wagon train going from New York to La?
My family would have either stayed,
I mean if you had little children,
you did stayed in Italy or Ireland,
you would have done whatever you could do to stay where you were.
But my,
uh,
Grandfather's family came over here and
I want to say the early 19 hundreds my grandfather's family came over from Italy
and my grandfather lived on a farm and he said,
tell me stories about how they used to kill rabbits with their hand,
like grandmother neck.
It's snapped them.
That was like a normal part of your life.
And there was,
you know,
winters where like,
they would run out of the food.
Like there was no food.
They didn't have to go and borrow food from people that were neighbors.
Crazy times crazy.
I know.
It's crazy.
More crazy is like,
can I say this?
I said this guessing Lee,
but like the amount of humility your grandfather must have had,
he was a very humble guy.
You like to come here.
Oh,
you know I,
he got walked on by my grandmother and my grandmother was like a really strong
woman and she used to yell at them all right.
I was like a little kid because my mom had me when she was 20 and you know,
my mom did her best but she was really young.
You know when you're 20 years old and all of sudden you're raising a baby,
that's a [inaudible] was 21 when I was born or where my,
um,
my mother was 21 rather when I was there,
I was 21 when I was born.
I might as well Ben and I would probably feel like,
oh my God,
this bitch is 21 she doesn't know what the fuck is going on.
I got to get up to
mentality immediately.
No,
they're all 40 they could have been,
no,
no.
At the time you were born,
I don't know.
I don't know old.
They were,
I mean
me to wrap my head around now I don't want to do the math,
but the point was my,
you know,
my mother was young and so like
growing up with like,
uh,
a young mother that doesn't necessarily know what the fuck is going on
really makes you realize at a young age like,
oh shit,
okay,
this isn't based.
You start looking at everything a little differently.
He doesn't know what's going on.
I don't think she can make no,
she was okay with that,
but
both in his fucking crazy thing together,
shit.
And you know,
you realize like kind of early
the fuck.
That's crazy.
I can't imagine being,
I can't imagine that my biggest hiccup in life was getting into standup because
by my,
I just that,
that I didn't,
I didn't have any humility at that time of my life.
And my dad gave me a speech on my 26th birthday that was like fucking
aggressive,
like really like 20 seconds.
The twenties.
It was on my birthday.
He called me and I thought,
he's going to wish me happy birthday.
And he was like,
you're a fucking loser.
Oh my.
He's like,
you make me embarrassed.
I'm embarrassing her,
my son,
I lie about you.
Oh my God,
he's,
do you know what that's like to love private,
to have a judge said,
I heard your son,
God is life's operating by raw Oliver stone and he's in New York turned
standard.
How's he doing?
Cause I lied in fucking court.
He goes,
it makes me sick to my stomach.
I was like,
what can I do different?
And he goes,
nothing.
I was like,
well,
can I fix this?
And he goes,
I know I failed you as a father.
And I know it.
It got me to like,
it changed my life.
Like I went,
he taught me how to get taught me how to be humble enough to get a job in
standup because I,
you just needed to work the door.
But I thought I was above that.
I thought that I was better than that.
Like I thought that someone would just grab me and put me on stage and I'd be
discovered.
That's how I thought it happened.
I didn't know.
You could literally be humble and say,
I want to do this.
How do I go about doing this?
Please help me test someone.
And he got me into it and literally fucking started doing it the next night and
six months later I had a deal and it was like,
it was a fucking,
one of the greatest things I ever did.
I look back at that so fondly.
Those times me like I outside,
this is every single night hanging outside.
Jim Norton,
Bobby Kelly,
Patrice O'neil,
Colin like not Colloquia.
And actually he didn't,
I didn't,
I've never actually met him until recently.
Just throw him in there.
Cause I,
I started getting into a tough crowd mentality.
I started living off the credits of tough crowd.
I was like me,
Bobby Kelly.
I'm honest.
I'd never,
I'd never met Nikki there.
So No,
I mean I've seen them come,
I worked the door when he'd come in and do the
club,
but I never knew.
You see him on stage.
It's fucking next brotherly love make us Nick Dipaolo to me is one of the most
underrated comedians in this kind of hands down.
No questions asked.
He's Kinda guy.
You can tell his jokes to your friend at a bar and they fucking lose their mind.
He had a joke about her.
You remember when Katrina hit do?
It's so cruel.
It was so,
it was so fucked up.
But he goes,
yeah,
they were.
They were writing rescue,
rescue,
rescue signs on the row,
on the roof.
But I'm not doing this any Josh.
I'm so sorry Ben.
And I was like,
there's no way I'll get through it.
There was signing a rescue,
uh,
you know,
signs on the roof,
but there were misses Belvin him instead of help,
but said Hap and once,
I'm happy to trick that fucking water
if you want some hap drink that water.
Nick Depaulo I'm not,
I'm sorry nick.
I butchered your joke.
Apologize.
I wish I knew his joke about he goes,
ah,
I'm not going to do this.
Ain't justice either.
They a lot of bills and they haven't said the n word.
A lot of people say that rarely.
I guess you'd never put $1,000 on a playoff game that
I know I ruined that bit,
but no,
no,
no.
Nick Depaulo was,
is one of the funniest.
I watched naughty,
naughty,
naughty and
I watched it.
Nordion rd and nick on uh,
on on the fucking same thing.
Damn.
Package shows on I want watch it cause I respect both of those guys so much that
I go,
it's not the best shows sometimes.
Well this is what I think that show would be fucking magic if it was uncensored
and to take nick and rd and putting on my regular like taking Joey d as in make
him instead of talk.
Write with a Crayon.
Yeah,
it's nonsense.
It's fucking stupid.
I watched it all the time though cause it's like I love nick and Arnie.
Someone with some fucking balls.
Please take that chair.
I'll put it on the Internet.
You'd make more money then they'll be more people that budgeting and you could
still put it on direct TV or whatever the fuck you're putting it on.
It's still would be,
but leave.
Let Nick Be Nick.
Let RDB already let him be crazy.
Let him,
let him talk completely unhindered
the way he,
what did I,
we were talking,
I was talking to someone recently about bottom lines and bottom line I go to
when you,
when you're doing bad in the hecklers attacking you and you have your comeback
and Nick Depaulo has a time,
I once again a butchering whatever this story is because I don't remember it,
but nick said that he was getting heckled by this girl and uh,
it was her bachelorette party and he was on the road and some podunk town and he
was like,
he was like,
ma'am,
I hope the next time you reach under your armpit you feel a lump.
And he goes,
I've never had an entire crowd hate me more.
And they had to escort him to the green room,
but he's a fucking liar.
Old School,
like old school,
kind of like,
that's the kind of dad I want Amit dads at like my kid's school.
And I wonder if they knew who the fuck I am.
Like then they,
then they do know who I am.
They figured out who I am,
they'll Google me and they'll go,
oh shit,
I knew you were.
This guy can be this guy around you.
Like I wonder,
I wonder if like parents,
cause he's got kids.
If they meet him and they have no clue of who he is and then like Google him and
then they're like,
oh my God,
I can tell this joke in front of you.
He's one of the funniest fucking human beings,
man.
I really,
very nice guy.
Do you ever do tough crowd?
Tough crowd was a definitive show on my life.
Yeah.
I would just have my first daughter show.
I've been doing the road and I would,
and I knew a lot of those guys.
Most of those guys from doing standard strategy that shows canceled.
It's so silly.
Bullshit.
Seems like like why would you ever,
I mean it's such an easy resource.
The,
you know,
it was easy to get comedians.
Everybody wanted to be on it.
It was very entertaining.
We'll get to talking to him like it's pretty much a podcast.
Yeah,
it wasn't fun.
It was a limited
like time,
a time limited podcast.
This,
listen man,
we're so lucky that we are existing in this time where you can do this thing
where you could do whatever the fuck you want.
No one's telling us what to do.
We're doing whenever we want.
We decided to keep going.
We decided to end the podcast,
take a leak and keep going.
There's no producers is don't.
That's the beauty of a situation.
Oh,
this is when Greg Giraldo and Denis leary hit pause for a second.
Brian,
this is a funny,
or keep it all your money story,
because Geraldo never even went to the nuclear weapons,
which is plagiarism.
He never went to that.
He never even went to that.
But Larry was so conti with them.
Like right off the bat,
Greg Giraldo was a buck and beautiful dude.
He was just the nicest fucking guy.
He was very intelligent in a,
in a,
in a time where in my life when no one needed to be nice to me.
There were two people that were distinctly nice to me and,
and,
and gentle and that was bill burr.
And Greg Geraldo like,
you know,
Norton and,
and,
and Bobby and all those guys were always nice to me.
But man,
good Geraldo and Bill Berg took time,
pulled me aside and like they were fucking great guys.
I remember one time calling in to my buddy cowhead show,
uh,
and,
and cause Geraldo was on and calling in to listen to Geraldo's interview cause I
just love Greg.
And I had told him and drag goes,
I'll put them on the phone and talk to him.
And I talked to Greg for like fucking 10 minutes in between the break in a song
and just was like,
man,
how,
how's everything going?
And he was like,
well yeah,
he was very sincere.
Fucking fucking great guy.
He had a show,
I don't remember what network it was on,
but it was,
uh,
it was his sitcom.
It was on during when yours was right?
Yeah.
He talked about partying with the girl that was on your show.
Which one?
Uh,
the girl with the big tits.
Who on newsradio girls are they tense?
Did Not one girl with big tits?
No.
Who was the girl?
And there was beautiful girls,
but then I always
have,
they,
I thought her tits were so big they had to tape them on.
Maura was the white girl with black hair.
Yeah,
she was though.
That's a really,
that's a terrible misunderstanding.
She was beautiful.
She was very beautiful and incredibly town home.
Fucking one incredibly town with white wine with her.
So bad.
I did a scene with her once,
I'll never forget this and I told her and she just sort of laughed it off
because she's,
she's like really?
Like she wasn't,
she would never like brag about her talent as an actor.
And he was good,
but we did a scene together and um,
I didn't that she was acting,
I thought she was saying something to me and I was like,
oh,
that's the words.
Oh,
well,
I go,
Holy Shit.
You bad ass bitch.
I go,
I didn't know you were acting.
you just fucking rocked me.
Like she rocked me with what she was saying because the set of news radio was
very loose.
There was a lot of fucking off.
And there was also a lot of improvisation where it's like Dave Foley was
responsible for a huge amount of like what got on the air,
that show,
because it's sort of like,
he was like sort of like a almost like a secret producer.
And it was because the guys who wrote the show where like they were so open
minded and so smart and Paul Simms,
who is the executive producer was just,
it's really brilliant guy who recognized that there was a lot of people like AMD
or like Phil Hartman or Dave Foley or whatever who would have this in intuition
while they were on stage working out the scenes and they would come up with new
things and to incorporate those new things.
So Dave was like constantly tweaking things and adding things and it was,
you know,
and being able to watch that and to watch someone do that and to be in that
situation,
I was like,
wow.
this is,
this is like an ideal situation.
He,
uh,
I,
I was the,
is this is gonna Sound Conti Conti but weird.
But,
uh,
so like last year was a very good year for me and I'm also in the middle of our,
our school.
So like our kids are in third grade and,
and like now we've been at school long enough to kind of work and we know all
the parents and so like I was this like a,
I was the resident famous comedian parent.
Like,
oh,
he's a comedian.
I think Dave Foley's kids go to our school now and Dave Foley,
they were like,
have you heard Dave Foley?
He spoke at a PTA.
Mom apparently is a fucking amazing dad.
Like I'm either that or it's a guy that looks like Dave Foley.
What do you mean he's amazing dad?
Like he like shows up and does all the shifts and,
and they were like,
no,
and I don't go into anything.
I don't even go to recitals.
Like I just fucking,
he's a very solid dude.
That was a great set.
But what I'm saying about Morris,
she d she was built,
oh yeah,
she's very pretty beautiful woman.
She didn't have big knocker.
She was fucking hottest shit.
She's very,
but you have a Greg Giraldo child across from you guys and you guys used to
party,
right?
And well,
we'll,
Greg was right
store and um,
he was,
there's a lot of guys who had TV shows.
There was a lot of guys who like got gigs back in those days.
It's like they got a development deal and maybe they had a few episodes.
Like my friend Tom Rhodes,
he had a show for sure.
Why can love Tom Rhodes.
He's a good dude.
He's a great dude.
And um,
I met Tom.
The first time I met him was when we were both on NBC.
I was on news radio and he had his own show and then he went over to Amsterdam
and he's,
Tom's beautiful,
he's fucking awesome.
But he never lost his shit,
you know,
he was,
he's always been cool.
He's always been like that.
The night I met Tom,
this is like,
in my opinion,
like a fucking ledge yet.
Comedian Tom Rhodes
is from Florida.
And,
uh,
I've told him the story a number of times and he never really it,
but we ran into each other in Amsterdam.
We did that showtime special with Russell Peters.
And I said,
uh,
the fucking first night I met him,
I was working in the Boston comedy club.
I came downstairs and he was at the bar and I knew it was from Florida and I was
from Florida and I like to stand up and I walked up to him and I was like,
I was like,
hey man,
my name's Bert.
I'm a comedian.
I just started,
I'd love to ask you.
And he stopped me,
like put his hand on my judge has handled Manchester was like,
listen,
you started buying beers and I'll answer every question you want.
No,
it's like,
all right.
So I started,
I put my fucking Dad's credit card down and I fucking Bob Beers and talked to
him about comedy for like three hours.
So it was fucking great.
He was one of the one dude's,
it did,
uh,
the icehouse chronicles and we had a long conversation afterwards.
Who was with you?
Yeah.
He was like the comradery.
So cool.
Here it's like we have like real comedian comradery.
He was hammered and I said I was with the two.
I think I was with the two I was with.
I had a guy with me to drive me and I,
I was like,
Tom,
let us take you to your cause he was hammered.
Yeah.
We were trying to tell him there's no way you're driving.
And he was like,
ah,
don't worry about me.
I sleep in a car.
I wake up and I go,
yeah,
he passed.
He slept in his car can do that.
That's illegal.
Well,
if he's sleeping in your car,
they'll arrest you.
I just had a simulation thing happened to me.
Joe.
I uh,
that,
that Denis leary video that we were talking about last night,
I watched this movie called happy,
which is all about depression and stuff like that.
It's a documentary on Netflix.
I recommend.
It's all right.
But there was a guy in the movie that was like a motivational speaker to kids
and I was like,
who is this guy?
It's the guy on the right right there.
I've never seen this guy.
Never in my life.
Yeah.
And now he's in this fucking bitch going to be on the podcast.
Oh,
are you serious?
I saw him the second time I ever did stand up for money.
I opened for Lenny Clarke.
I used to say it was the first time,
but it's a lie.
Ladies and gentleman.
The first time I opened up a guy named Warren Mcdonald's.
That's the first time I ever got paid.
But the second time I ever got paid,
the truth is I opened up for Lenny Clarke and I was in a place called js and
Pittsfield,
Massachusetts and Lenny.
Um,
he's always been like super cool to me.
He's going to look how fat Greg Looks.
Does it look grow fat will considering like,
oh now.
Oh Brian,
where you saw that bit.
At least you know that Greg would have been going on.
I was a horrible joke.
Yeah.
The big guy,
by the way,
Lenny has lost a shitload of weight.
Yeah.
Lenny is really good.
Wait,
wait.
Is this serious?
In that documentary he was pulling out towels because he wouldn't stop sweating.
And I was telling,
I was talking to the girl I was with last night and I was like,
isn't that crazy?
He's just standing there talking to kids and he can't stop sweating.
There's like sweat all over his body.
It's documentary.
It's called happy and I just saw it last night and never seen this guy before in
my life and I just pull up this video and he's in this video.
It's so fucking,
where's the part where Greg,
we did that.
A movie together.
Here comes the boom,
the Kevin movie and Lenny Clarke was in that movie because it was shot in Boston
and Lenny played a local Boston guy,
Lenny Clarke,
which I fucking love that guy,
but he's lost a lot of weight man.
He lost a ton of where he looks great.
I mean he's like really lean.
He doesn't have a,
I've got it.
All right,
Dalia guy gotta work right
for reasonable price.
And I could come back,
we get out of a piece and like they did an,
is this where they might find out?
Well,
it's,
it's about the time,
I think right here.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
what happened to lap Denis leary?
He gets mad at Greg.
Geraldo has prepared material.
It's really hilarious.
And that's how he found out where they were buried the ball.
Yeah,
I know.
Is it during the Dukes of Hazzard?
I dunno,
someone should find this off air and figure it out because it's a really good
job.
Well,
there might be their outcome for a,
what is a nonviolent way to,
to solve the problem with the copy that we hate,
that hate dozens got weapons pointed this?
I don't think so.
No,
you're right.
Like Russia for example,
that big Russian war.
Yeah.
There are things that,
there are things that are
absolutely,
but there our approach to their economic benefit that we're giving them in order
to,
for them to stop developing their weapons.
I mean,
I heard weekly they agree to stop,
uh,
stop building nuke.
If American women agree to get their nails done,
at least twice a week.
I ran a good boy.
You're,
you can make so many jokes before the show.
It's not even applying.
Unbelievable.
He's got to,
he's got pocket follow.
Not Good.
I'm just saying.
I don't know.
I'll have,
it was my dad.
That's kind of what we do here.
A comedy writer.
Oh boy.
The guy who did all the homework and then after there was any more that needed
to be done.
That's a good point.
And if you would try it,
a little comedy writing,
maybe your show and still be on the air.
Can you tell me all the time
he just crushed it,
you know?
But that's
[inaudible] happens when dudes get famous.
I think you guy can't come along and clown.
You
tell me about it.
It's a first time I went on the road and I realize there are killers that I've
never heard of.
No.
When a guy gets famous to a point where you're uh,
uh,
Tom Cruise or any,
any,
any sort of a person who's been in moving.
Yeah,
Dennis Leary,
when that came out and had been in a ton of movies,
he had been in some really high profile movies.
I mean he thought of himself as a guy who had made it so I think he probably
assumed he was going to get a certain level of respect.
So
maybe if you did a little writing your show would still be on the air.
That was like a nuclear weapon that he didn't see common.
He didn't see that.
Tell
me that all you got detonated is that,
oh for that was Hubris.
You look at the look on journalists face and you can see his eyes twitching and
you can see him go angry going three,
two,
I got this,
I got this and then like making is making it as tactical colonists had.
You could see that happening almost.
It's a superior mind,
superior mind,
just not as famous but a superior product.
Like what he would,
he would put out his points of view,
it'd be superior.
I'll watch his hour.
I got the idea that there would be like something funny and sign it.
Someone prepared like look at him.
He for being a bully.
But that's the idea.
That was ridiculous.
Like it's so crazy like,
oh look at the painter.
He went and painted
like,
what the fuck?
It's a,
there's a,
there's a certain personality that,
and I'm not going to speak,
I don't,
I'm not saying this is Denis leary,
but there is certain personality that's so arrogant in that the way I say it
will be so much better than the way you say it,
as opposed to what I say is better than what you say.
So like,
like you could hear the statement before him when he says,
oh,
well we're going to go to war with a country like the,
it was very arrogant and he was like,
yeah,
like that great Russian war that does fucking work.
You're not listen to the words you're,
you're,
you're overlooking the thought.
Well,
he hasn't this idea that somehow or another he's going to be able to solve what
hundreds of scholars and heads of states and diplomats and emissary workers and
no one can solve.
No one can solve.
But he's going to come along and tell you exactly how things need to be blunt.
The ideas of,
first of all,
the communication between nations where they don't even speak the same fucking
language.
Yeah.
And how difficult that shit is.
It's so fucking hard just to understand things and cultural context and explain
those different people that are in your country that you're sort of
representing.
Because Koreans are not like Americans and Americans and all I Koreans,
people that live in North Korea do not understand how we're living in North
America and the people in North America for the most part,
really a fairly ignorant about what the fuck is going on in North Korea.
And one of the big reasons is because we can't fuck them communicate with each
other.
If we could communicate with each other,
if everybody in Korean and North Korea knew how to speak English and they all
could read the shit on the Internet about how the world is run and what the fuck
is really going on in the country and how the rest of the world views things,
they would probably slowly but surely take action.
But the fact that there they're separate from the rest of the world,
in fact they speak this one,
you know,
very unique sort of a language.
It's difficult to learn and he's in translatable very easily to English or
Spanish or
there's Korean.
Not translatable is difficult
symbol.
You know the,
the,
this,
the way things are written,
we're good friends are Korean and that when you go to a car,
we went to a Korean barbecue.
It was Roy Choi.
He's the guy that started the Taco truck.
The concept of the TACO truck.
It's him.
He started,
it started.
It was the first guy,
the premise of these correlation,
these gourmet taco trucks.
He's Asian.
Yeah.
Roy Choi.
He does.
He's good friends with Bordain Asians don't give a fuck dude.
Then you get things done.
They get things done.
I don't think they really get it done.
If I can get things done,
they really do the fucking future of America.
When you eat,
how the fuck did they ever figure out how to get,
I don't even know what you've said yet.
Full.
A full like strangle hold on the manufacturer of like electronic parts and TV's
and lab
cars.
Cars,
cars are over there now.
They're going to wear in Detroit.
No one's doing cars in Detroit.
Well,
isn't Chrysler stolen to Detroit and hasn't forward?
No,
but no one's in Detroit.
Detroit's apparently imperil because everyone took their business to Asia.
Why?
It's,
it's more,
is it more,
is it more a,
an idiocracy not idiocracy a theocracy,
not theocracy.
What's worth looking for?
Any is a accuracy.
What do you,
what are you trying to where like where it's like the idea of the state is
better than the person.
So everyone looks up to the state and it's something like that where they care
about their job.
Like Americans just don't care.
Well,
you know what happened is first of all the cars they made sucked that that
happened in American.
Yeah.
This something happened.
We have to,
there was a period where we got really lazy.
What the fuck went wrong from like 1973 the Ford Tempo and 90 fucking Ford tempo
is a fucking was a,
that was a phone in job by the American.
Like that car sat dick Suck Dick in 1989 Ford tempo
for Tiempo.
What the fuck happened to the Mustang?
Okay.
Because I can say this,
I can say this,
I have a Mustang today.
I have a Shelby gt 500 and I fucking love it.
Okay.
But that's a 2010 and between like 1965 and 1972 or 73 they had some dope
fucking car.
Really like to 69 but then something happened and like the 70s and the 80s like
you call that up fucking Mustang.
What are you a communist?
What did would a terrorist infiltrate the fucking the four plants and hold down
the designers by gunpoint and gay up all the drawings.
I go,
oh fuck.
Do you call that by the way I spelled gay.
G H e y them gave them Joe homosexuals
like,
cause I wonder if it was a,
it had to do with homosexuality and the,
and the fear of homophobia.
And they took all these great gay designers that were super closeted in the
fifties and then got,
and then there was this manliness and they disappeared.
You trying to say that Dick Suck and design the corvette?
No,
there's no way you can tell me as a man,
what is sexy without knowing sexy as a man.
What the fuck are you talking about Pete Townsend?
Corvette is the sexiest car you can put me in.
Is it really?
I just drove one from Miami to Marco Island and I tell you right now,
the second I sat in that seat,
I would let the steering wheel be close to my face cause I wanted it there.
It was just fucking,
it was God,
God kind of car.
Was it a corvette?
Which here?
Brand new,
brand new 3000 miles convertible.
There's new ones.
Was it a four 26 I have no,
I have no idea what 26 is.
They have the zero six zero six engine and suspension and okay.
Convertible.
So fucking hot.
Like I just melt Cooley Shit.
Now
that's not a corvette,
Brian.
That's a god Damn Miata and it's pink.
How dare you?
How dare you hate America on this podcast hating or my rook.
Cool.
I got to pimp.
Well,
why don't you go poop man.
We'll wait.
We'll hold on.
Yeah.
What time is your ra common show tonight,
Brian.
And can kind of,
can we guide people in your general direction?
I'm just going to try to get up somewhere now.
When you do that,
what do you do?
You just show up and say,
oh I didn't try to sneak my way in.
Hey,
my name's Brian Red Band and you might know me on Twitter.
Is that what you do?
Why don't you start it started start a a room.
Your own Brian.
Huh?
I did.
I have like three rooms every.
So do you think ever will
be all contained under one roof?
Do you think that ever the full desk squad family will have podcast studios in
one gigantic warehouse and cause that's what I'm saying.
I'm at the saying we also duplicate this at the Onnit compound in Texas.
Why didn't,
why not?
Yes.
Austin fence.
Thousands of acres are on lake plus deer to shoot.
How do we get it?
How do we get a power bitch?
Did I say what?
What?
Maybe we can have her own fucking satellite.
Okay.
How do we get it?
Oh,
like a death squad,
like studio in a warehouse where we can make TV shows.
I don't want to make it a CV,
so why not?
Why not?
It just needs to be an umbrella.
If I'm making a TV show,
here's my next TV show.
I'm going to play it
cool.
Around the spine.
Is Boring,
boring for you bitch?
It's not 99% of the people
he is.
We were very close to a sign.
I can't say with WHO.
There's a,
there's a show that is a,
um,
uh,
a lot of it is based in the podcast.
What are you doing?
Taking text messages?
Come at them live on the air.
No,
this person said that they got a new phone number.
They're like,
sorry,
I got a new phone number and I thought they were lying,
but now they're sending me pictures of this.
Is that,
is that,
who is that?
It's an Aussie.
Is that Kadafi?
Yeah.
All right,
so might be not the person I'm thinking of it.
Okay.
You getting someone sending you a murder?
The people.
What's that?
What's a new TV show you're doing?
Oh,
it's uh,
it's based a lot of it on his like controversial subjects and a lot of it,
it'll be all of it.
We'll start off from the podcast,
like examining all sorts of different ways.
There's no tenant,
well,
we sort of have a tentative title,
but I'm not necessarily happy with it.
So the idea is like the way we've done the podcast where we explore all these
different ideas,
whether it's a shamanism or,
or big foot or Ufo shows are fringe topics,
crop circles,
reincarnation,
psychics,
and we're going to talk about it on the podcast.
I'll have a guy like you or Ari or Duncan or Jolie or any comedian come on and
we'll say,
you know what?
It's like,
we'll do it right now.
What do you think about big foot?
Do you think?
Do you think that is possible?
There could be an undiscovered primate that people have been talking about
reporting for ages and it's somehow or another,
it alluded photography except for a few really questionable photos and some
really fucking shitty video that looks fake as fuck.
Put all that aside,
Paul,
the hoaxes aside,
do you think it's possible?
It's possible.
100%.
Why do you think?
Cause I believe,
whoa.
Yeah.
I believe,
wow.
I believe in Loch lochness monster.
I believe in Tuba.
Coffee can fly.
Do I believe I can fly
pee on you if you're a 14 year old girl and you didn't know why you were there?
I definitely believe that I have the capability to fly in my body.
I just haven't figured it out.
And we'll,
once we do tap into that,
I will be able to fly.
Okay.
But like Bill Hicks,
she used to say star on the ground floor,
like set a great joke about the young man acid.
Thought he could fly lept to his death.
What a tragedy it goes when an idiot because you taught him can fly.
Why did he start off from the ground go?
You feel like that?
I remember when Star Wars Wars,
Star wars return of the Jedi came out.
No,
no,
no.
Uh,
empire strikes back came out.
I remember watching Luke move stuff with his mind and I remember being in the
back of my car trying to do that hardest fuck,
like staring at objects,
trying to make shit swear to God.
I was like,
that seems logical.
Well,
there's certain aspects of life it seems so preposterous.
Unrelenting electricity.
What the fuck is that?
It just hits you.
Have you seen those Tesla and
like experiments where he's like touching electricity and it was like a Bolton's
flying big Tesla coil and is connected to his arm.
Hold on.
Have you seen any of those photos?
Did Tesla just can I,
have you seen the new Tesla fucking car?
Did you see them all explode when hurricane sandy hit the beach in a,
in,
in New Jersey?
What?
Yeah,
there was a whole warehouse that had like this.
Uh,
they were,
uh,
they had a dock in,
they had all these new
Karmas.
That's what it was.
The Fisker Karma.
Was it a Tesla as though
the grant?
It's,
it looks gorgeous.
Quite a few.
Yeah.
Really beautiful electric cars right now.
But the Fisker Karma is the one and they have like a 16 of them I think exploded
on the,
on the docks.
They had them on the docks and the water came up on the water,
hit these fucking electric
transformer clocking blew up and everybody was like,
Oh okay.
Shit.
I don't think they knew that would happen.
What happens if you drive?
We're fucking standing water.
What have you tried to home from a flood?
Is Your fucking car explode?
Okay.
Cause I can deal with my car shorting out.
It's sitting,
they're scared to leave.
If I can save like two bucks a gallon,
but my car explodes when I hit a puddle.
Is that going to happen?
Is that what the fuck is really going on?
That does that Tessa looks bad.
Shit,
we've won a,
it was either murdered,
murdered motor trend or road and track car of the year.
One of those big magazines made it the car,
the or the uh,
Tesla.
Not The roadster,
but the larger car.
Something that something asks.
It's a like a four door and uh,
apparently it's just a marvel of engineering.
But
the real problem is going to be a row state taxes on roads.
The roads are going to shit.
This is a lot
problems though.
Then another problem is the fact that everybody wants to pretend that buying
some sort of an electric car removes you from the fossil fuel food chain.
Yeah,
but it doesn't and in fact it connects you with some even shady or minerals on
like a really large scale like lithium ion and all those different minerals.
A lot of those or conflict minerals.
They come from the Congo,
they come from Afghanistan.
They come from like if I was Brian Count,
I'd say I've got a stone.
If I was a amber Lyon,
I'd say,
uh,
what was it?
She was fine.
Bahrain please.
Not In the bottom lane lane.
Yeah.
The,
you know these,
these minerals that you,
you need to create a lithium ion battery by the way.
Mad Labs,
Brian Callan and mad love to amber line,
which is fucking with you.
Those minerals that you need to make batteries.
They come from like really fucking imprisoned and poverished areas.
Their conflict minerals.
Lithium ion is officially like a conflict mineral.
Like a lot of the shit that you need to even make cell phones.
It's like,
I think vice had a guide they had,
they did a a vice guide to travel episode where Shane Smith went to the Congo.
I don't know why they're not all the travel channel.
I would love to see one of their fucking shows because it's too deep.
They go to the same shipboard aim does.
No,
they go way further than Baroda and
further extended mean close Simon clothes where vice vice goes to the fucking
Congo deep,
deep,
deep and talks to warlords.
Really?
Did they go looking for dinosaur?
Yeah,
I would.
I'd love to see that.
I didn't they you put that on,
why not?
We enjoy watching her on the Internet.
Why can't travel boy
your correct.
However,
most people that run these organizations,
whether it's a network or you know,
you know cable or,
or whether it was broadcast television,
they,
they're very conservative because they're trying to sell advertising.
Yeah.
So when a,
when a company like vice comes along and they have like really they have no
respect for any corporation at all because they'll do what the fuck they need to
do to make what they think.
They have videos where Hamilton Morris goes into the jungle and he's taking
Chris Drugs and align on his back and you know,
I mean it's like they're not going to sell tide during those times.
You know,
they're going to have to accept that they're not yourself time.
But they do see that's what's really stupid.
It's like there's weird sort
of game that we play.
Whereas we pretend that the people that see all the fucked up things that you
can find on the Internet are not the same people that wash their clothes.
Yeah.
That wash their clothes or wash my clothes,
my gas or any of the variables and the end of the things where we try to target
people.
We're all,
we're all the same fucking people man.
And yet we just have access to different shit.
Now we need to accept that.
You need to just stop pretending that we're living in some sort of a Catholic
school,
you know,
a Sandra Bullock movie view of the world.
It's not,
it's not reality.
Reality is there's a lot of fucked up shit about out there and I can find it
now.
I can find it on the Internet.
It's really easy.
So you need to sort of adjust your expectations accordingly because there's a
lot of evidence,
a lot of evidence that shows that reality.
It's pretty fucking slippery.
Yeah.
There's a lot of nutty shit outfit,
but that tells the car looks bad is fuck yeah,
but it will explode if he hit a puddle.
What a horrible feeling.
It look dope.
I like the,
uh,
that's the four 26.
That one that Brian just put up as the,
uh,
the new corvette convertible.
That's,
it's got a 505 horsepower.
The last version of this,
uh,
this engine,
I think it's called the ls one,
but it's a,
might be wrong,
but it's a huge fucking power and torque that's also in the Zr one,
the same engine.
They supercharge it and the Zr one,
it produces 648 horsepower.
This is like for people who like talk about like muscle cars.
This is like the greatest era of a muscle cars in the history of the fucking
world,
Nolan.
Yeah.
The muscle cars that people are creating now actually can take turns and they
actually have good brakes.
Like this is a Shelby Mustang they have now.
That's unbelievable.
The regular button,
they have the three Oh two boss Mustang.
That's like,
you know,
it's like,
they're like moderately powered.
It has 440 fucking horsepower.
It's unbelievably powerful.
Is it the Dodge Dodge Challenger challenger?
Yeah.
We went to muscle car though.
Then we went to drive um,
uh,
Lamborghini's and Ferrari's and Porsche's on a track for a triplet and the
dude's just wanted to drive the dodge challenger.
They would take you out for a ride and they were like,
this is more fun for us to drive.
Why is that?
I have no fucking idea.
But they did everything and they do the,
the,
the burnouts where they spin in circles.
Like it's just more fun.
Like the,
those things.
I,
you know,
I think like,
I definitely have driven a ton of those,
uh,
Lamborghini type cars.
Those things are fun as fuck,
but it is a different drive than like it is really,
you don't feel as loose maybe as you do as a dodge challenger and dodge
challenger.
You're fucking sliding and you're,
it's fun feeling it.
Yeah.
Well they have a,
they
have a broad sort of a um,
uh,
you could pick from like a lower horsepower engine to like a really ridiculous
engine and those things.
Yeah,
you could like ramp
it up and there's a lot of people take those cars and they ramp them up even
more.
Like the Hennessy Hennessy makes a 700 horsepower when those I love and that you
get like those special edition cars.
Yeah.
Well what they are though,
like the muscle cars of old,
those things,
you couldn't take corners in them like this.
These are completely different animals,
but the challenger is still like a muscle car.
Whereas like the Camaro has become almost like a sports car because they handle
so well.
Might've been,
it might've been a Camaro they were driving now that I'm thinking about it,
but like we were taking corners in the lamb,
Lamborghini and like 90 miles an hour.
Yeah.
Taking corners fucking insane.
You can do ridiculous shit with sports cars.
I drove,
I flew to Italy for a day to drive a Ferrari down the coast.
Like I had to fly,
I had to drive a flight.
I think I texted you about it.
Yeah.
Which one did you drive?
Uh,
I have no fucking clue,
but it was,
I just drove down the coast and I had a chase car in front of me and test score
by me.
They just taped it and I just fucking Lou,
why was so much fun?
Like those paddles up,
up,
up.
Just for lying.
Yeah.
Those paddle shifters.
A lot of people are upset about that shit though.
A lot of people think that a real sports guy,
you should shift it manually and that just because it's quicker to shift it with
the paddles,
like you're missing out on part of the experience.
And I kind of agree,
man,
because I like shifting my own gears.
I just do fun about it.
I did too,
but there's so many people that probably have never learned how to do that.
They can't learn on a Ferrari,
and I'm sure that's just a sales thing because the paddle shifters are much
easier.
Yeah,
way,
ways,
but it's not as satisfying.
It's not,
it's not that it's hard to shift.
You're on gears,
but there's something that's like mechanically engaging about the clutch in
sliding and shifter for letting the clutch out,
hitting the gas the same time.
So it was something super sexy when you met a girl that knew how to drive a
stick and you were like,
yeah,
like,
you got to,
you're a good dad.
Especially if it was like a fucking Mustang or something crazy.
This dirty pitches out there driving a big fat VA,
blah,
blah.
She wants to drive.
When you go to the movies and you've got to say no,
and you've got to not let it be on top of the first time we fuck either.
It's very important and then establish dominance immediately.
Bert Kreischer that I grabbed that bitch and let her know the feeling of gravity
and the density of the bones and your hips.
You know what I'm saying?
Brian?
Hollaback.
Ooh.
So bird crusher.
How much time do you spend on the road?
Lately?
I'm fucking Dick load.
I'm on the road every week.
I feel like I'm home two days this week.
I'm going to take a leak.
Talked to Brian about it.
Okay.
This is in the podcast.
It's been four hours.
Just five minutes.
Brian,
I'll tell you a story.
All right.
Tell me a story.
City.
Okay.
Um,
do you wanna hear the story?
I,
that I had going to make it.
Oh,
okay.
I'll tell you a good story.
It's story.
This is the reason no listened to the Brian Bird podcast
because I find you funny too often.
Oh,
thank you.
I find you funny all the time.
No,
no.
But we like,
like I listened to the podcast and when I hear you say things that fucking fit
maybe stopped Joe or like dice,
like you said,
like two or three things that made me laugh so hard during the dice podcast.
I'm smoking in the studio right now.
Like a bad boy.
What's in that room right there?
That's a behind me is just an empty room.
There's a lot of empty rooms here at the studio.
So I'll tell you this story.
Okay,
Brian.
All right.
Um,
so I checked into,
I did Columbus and then I did right after that I did at Kentucky,
right?
Chucked into the Kentucky Hotel.
Uh,
the hotel in Kentucky and I have four bags.
I shirts,
I've shirts for two weeks.
So I four bags a bellman takes my bags,
take some,
I have to take it,
let them take it in my room.
You know,
he's going to get a tip.
We go in the elevator.
He asked what I do.
I said,
I'm a comic.
We get out and second our door opens,
another door opens and it's a,
it's a older white dude.
And he walks out like three steps behind us and he follows me down the hallway,
three steps behind us,
all the way,
all the way until we get to the end of the row,
the hall where my door is and I'm like,
is he going to my room?
Turns out he's in the room directly next to mine.
So as he goes to open the door and like,
like put his key in.
I jokingly in front of this bellman thinking,
he laugh.
I go,
hey man,
if you want,
we can open up that center door and hang out all weekend.
And the guy now I like nervous and not,
and he's trying to get his key in and he's like,
no,
I don't.
I don't want to do that.
And I go,
well,
it could be cool with like get to know them.
I said this to this guy,
say that,
take it fucking around,
I'm going to kiss you or so just fucking around or even bring that up.
We'll just fucking around.
Just fucking round as a comic.
Should do.
All right,
but what if he says yes,
I don't think he will.
He's an older man,
but what if he did?
He's an older man.
I'll tell you.
Let me tell you.
Let me,
I'll tell you the story.
That's why get I checked into the
Kentucky and I got to do the Kentucky and or whatever to Louisville and I have
four bags with me and the bellman takes my bags up the elevator for me and I got
them on.
Is this a gay store?
No,
it's not at all.
It's really,
it's one of the funnier things I've done in a little bit of music to the back of
it.
Yeah.
This is,
this is a strong enough story to close the podcast that way.
It might be,
might be roadkill,
ghosts,
choir,
beggars guild,
and we're going to play that in the background.
Come on,
sweetie.
Let me design this thing.
I know what I'm doing.
Trust me.
Oh,
did you pull up miss B?
You can't kiss me.
You got to stop that.
You know,
we're playing that out.
We already did that today with a Brad Pitt,
Stephen Dorff,
the roadkill ghost choir,
and the song is
beggars guild.
We need to get a desk,
quad iTunes account.
Don't you just order things online?
You know,
we need real internet.
Hi.
Real Internet death squad one.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll do,
we can do one this week,
Sarah.
We want to do Fridays there.
We could do Fridays.
There was a column because I had the ice house.
Okay.
Beautiful.
All right here.
Is that no Bert Kreischer what were you trying to tell me?
Who are you telling me,
buddy?
What were you telling me?
Columbus,
Ohio.
Fuck Nick.
Nick.
I just invented it so I never heard it myself.
Probably the wrong song for this button.
It's the perfect song fest.
So tell me what happened.
A little,
a little fine.
Plus we had a little more volume.
So I check into the Kentucky Improv and a black dude texted my bags.
He grabs my bags,
puts him on the trail trailer thing,
brings him to the elevator.
I got to let him take it in the room.
He's earned his tip.
Right,
right,
right.
So we take them up to my room.
He says,
what are you doing something,
a comedian?
He goes,
okay.
And we don't talk.
After that door's open,
it's word elevator door to open the doors next to us in the elevator next to us
to open and an older white dude walks out and follows us.
Any ghosts us down like the whole hallway.
Everywhere we go,
he follows us.
He's going wherever the fuck we're growing,
but get all the way down to the end of the hallway.
How far away is he walking behind you?
Three feet behind us the whole time.
That mother fucker unconscious.
It's awkward.
It's awkward and we're both know.
Didn't confront him all noticing it.
So we get to the last door and I'm thinking,
is this guy going to my room?
I would assume that guys try and do something bad.
You did something really wrong going on,
but I would think though,
why would you do what we do it?
What would the last thing you would do,
Joe?
Listen,
here's what happens.
First of all,
when someone is mirroring you like that three,
there'd being very disrespectful because they're not,
they're not just the,
not just following you.
They're letting you know they're following you and they're doing it in a very
arrogant way or they're being flirty?
Well,
they could be.
There's what happened?
Could be psychotics.
Here's what happened or what would you do?
Meet up immediately.
I would ask them what the fuck is going on?
Watch what he does.
It turns out he's in the room next to me.
So he was going to his room.
So as he goes I was drunk.
See you're paranoid.
Nobody was thinking about it.
Who is scared about life?
I have a lot,
a lot.
I was thinking about more black.
I knew I was a comic and I wanted him to nudes know that I knew Kevin Hart cause
that's what I thought he was going to.
No,
no.
Hold on.
And so the guy,
the guy,
old guy goes to open his door and I jokingly now told the Black Guy,
I'm a comic but I haven't done anything funny.
So I jokingly look at the old guy and I go pay if you want,
we can open up that connecting door and we can hang out.
Always.
It gets better.
It gets better by to the guys now can't get his,
cause he's now had panicked him and he can't get this door open.
And he goes,
no,
I don't want that happened.
And I go,
no,
it'd be cool man.
We'll open it up or hang out with like the darkness and just talk to each other
at night and he can't get his door open and finding is this door open?
And he goes,
I don't want that to happen.
The door opens before you can close it.
I stick my head in and I go,
hey man,
if you change your mind,
knock and scratch.
So he goes,
no.
And he shuts the door and he's
fucking panicked.
And I looked to the black guy,
the black guy's gone,
he's in my room.
Okay.
So I go,
fuck.
I did that joke for nothing.
So I go into the room and the was putting the bags down and uh,
he gets done all the bags and I go to take,
you might want to get ready to cue the music.
Brian,
he,
I go to give him a tip and the black guy looks at me and shakes his head and he
goes,
no.
I said,
well,
I've got to give you a tip.
He took my bags up here and he goes,
no,
just knocking scratch.
So I look at the black,
I go,
okay.
So I knock and I scratch to the room goes,
he's on the ground.
Like so the guy in an extra room called downstairs?
No,
no,
no.
The Black Guy,
the guy who I told the joke for in the first place,
I heard the whole thing and he goes,
no man,
don't do it.
You got to knock and scratch.
So I knocked his scratched and the fucking guys like,
I don't want to hang out,
man.
Bird crashed.
That's rude.
Oh,
it was fucking the funniest guy in a bar or die with a lot of insecurity and
you're fucking with his head.
Funniest thing I've ever done.
The bed's Kinda bullyish.
You feel bad for that poor dude ass so bad.
The whole
weekend.
I kept talking loud as fuck in my room.
Just going.
I know he's listening to me.
Why don't you just knock on the door and say,
hey man,
I'm a comedian.
I'm really sorry it was passed.
It was passed.
That is past that.
Oh,
so you had to just like fucking just
burn all the evidence.
You just had a fucking shoot rockets from helicopters.
Is this incredible hulk music is the end.
This is the,
I could fuck it.
I could do the my
friend.
Well thank you very much Debra.
Crisis One Ohio.
You Sir are a bad motherfucker.
Has such a great time today.
Ma'Am.
You're welcome.
Anytime my friend,
if there's anything we could do to help you in any way,
shape
forum,
you've done everything you could imagine my vodka company when it starts,
well not us know Bert Kreischer.
We will launch that bitch machine vodka in motion.
Lazy Gentlemen Machine Vodka just became an official sponsor
of the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
They have one year free sponsorship.
We will talk about machine vodka for one year is absolutely zero money and you
will buy it all up and Bert Kreischer.
We'll have a helicopter and a place on a volcano in Hawaii so
I can fly to our Texas compound with our high wall or crisis kind of by Terence
Mckenna's house on the big island and converted into a Bikini factory where the
hottest girls in the world will make $1,000 an hour and they'll make bikinis and
leaving Easter will be one of my models.
Exactly.
With Rachael Ray,
les Miserables.
Bulls will play in the background until everyone becomes a sex slave.
Zombie robot control afternoon to talking.
Yeah,
it was beautiful.
This is what we
should do all the time,
but do this once a week.
You were the reason I have a podcast,
I am grateful.
Fucking days in the podcast is successful,
but Brian,
you know how I know how to get a cup pod cast up.
We are all together in this crazy soup of life.
Bert Kreischer.
Yeah,
I am as happy for you as you are for me.
We are both together.
Very fortunate along with Jamie,
the new guy along with Brian.
You said anything Jamie,
shut up and it's not ready yet.
It's not ready to go through an apprenticeship.
You need to see success and failure.
Just
like puzzles.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is the end of the commercial free podcast here at the Joe Rogan experience.
What can you do to give thanks,
wait,
can you do incorporate all the messages of the Bert Kreischer,
Bert,
Bert podcasts into your life,
bitches,
bird cast,
baby.
Check it out.
The Burt cast at Bert Bert,
bert.com you can find all the information.
Incorporate those lessons to Dli.
Hey,
don't be a con.
Be looking in the mirror.
See,
get Josh Gad up pictures and shit together.
We love you,
but first you must love yourself in order for you to love yourself.
You must respect herself in order for you to respect yourself.
You need to get your shit together,
bitch.
Give yourself advice for 10 you are an outside and objective observer of your
own existence.
And what kind of advice would you give yourself to get your shit together and
why won't you follow that Shit Yourself?
Stop pretending you can't bullshit a bullshitter.
Socket that squad 2013 bitches.
Where here,
fuck up my Mayan raise Odin son.
Praise Odin bitches.
Oh,
Adam knows what the fuck is up.
We'd go to rubbing.ting.com and save 50 bucks and goblets Jihad.